[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
حركه الهواء من مكان الى مكان اخر تسمى
بالرياح فهي تنتقل من مكان الضغط العالي
الى مكان الضغط
المنخفض وكلما زاد الفارق بينهما زادت حده
عصف الريح والمنخفضات والمرتفعات محليه
وعالميه فمع دخول موسم الصيف الفعلي يبدا
يؤثر علينا منخفض الهند برياح السموم ومع
دخول موسم الشتاء الفعلي يبدا يؤثر علينا
المرتفع السيبيري بالرياح الشماليه
البارده خلال موسم المربعانيه والشبط
والعقارب تهب كل رياح الارض عاصفه والنخل
لا تنحني الا ذوائبه ان كبيره كبيره
مصائبه
فتغير الاحوال الجويه عن سائد هذا مؤشر
على تدخل مناخي مغايره عن السائد فسائد في
الشتاء البروده احيانا تنكمش البروده
ويعود الدفء وهذا مؤشر على قرب سحب ماطره
واحيانا تنقشع هذه السحب ويزرقها وجه
السماء وهذا مؤشر على قرب رياح بارده
والعامه يقولون البرد وجهه وجذيب ما تدري
معين يجيك
[موسيقى]